joe takes the bound at nats park for the
first time since game five of the 2019
world series
last start on the 14th against the
cardinals 6-0 winner six shutout on four
hits tommy edmond has been a road
warrior and he brings the slider
from the back door to get the swinging
strikeout so you saw a couple of those
fastballs whistle in there we've been
talking about how heavy the joe ross
sinker has been to start the 2021 season
but the sliders been nice too and that's
a tough guy to strike out and here is
goldschmidt setting up right on the
outside edge and there's another slider
two up two down swinging it seems like
the opponents aren't picking up the
rotation on the joe ross slider what
does that mean it's tight it's late you
see right there good shot of it nolan
aronado's off to a good start with his
new ball club he's a 293 career hitter
popped him up
joe's going to do it all in the top of
the first
nobody else needed to touch the ball
except for jan gomez
well we all know jack flaherty obviously
good for seeing fastball when he's down
he can spot it doesn't throw a lot of
two seamers although his ball does run i
think he throws more two seamers than we
think and then the breaking ball the
slider which is nasty
and not a whole lot of change-ups
there's trey turner behind his back the
second time
in the last couple weeks that he's
taking a
a ball off the hand a little bit right
there
boy let's hope he's all right cardinals
really were aggressive with bell with
fastballs last week and the 3-2 pitch
ground ball
loved by arenado
ranging to his left to make that play
one two three go to the nationals
there's no score
here's de young
down the left-field line and gone
off the foul pole an absolute
rocket off the bat
of paul de young
his fourth home run and it's one nothing
cardinals
on a solo shot here in the second look
at the swing it is nothing other than
staying back pulling your hands in and
hitting the barrel where all you young
kids out there talk about all the time
you don't swing hard to hit home runs
you swing right you balance you hit the
barrel and you get extension carpenter
with an rbi in a wacko for five career
against
joe ross
swing
and a miss on the slider
three strikeouts for joe ross
and the battery is starlin castro
jack flaherty by the way is one
strikeout away from 500 in his career
and a ground ball to short chopped to de
young
and that is six up six down for flaherty
could be in for a pitchers duel here
tonight both guys have been sharp early
on a little bit of movement let's hit
the other way and a base hit for justin
williams he's got a little pop going the
other way doesn't he the extension is
insane and that's when you get to see
the exit velocity there's tommy edmund
struck out his first time up here's the
3-0 pitch
lifted in the air
left center robles back looks up gone
it's a home run and a frustrated fan it
was there for him to have a souvenir
it's not only a two-run homer he missed
the ball
what do you think he's more mad about
the humper or not catching it both
that was a great at-bat by tommy edmond
right there 3-0
this we talked about last night you
gotta swing the bat when you get a guy
that throws balls like this and you get
a count that you can be aggressive in go
for it
one and two with one out to goldschmidt
that is launched out to left
back to back
they've done it again
back-to-back homers they did that twice
on saturday and for the first time
tonight back-to-back home runs edmond
and goldie good contact right there and
that's just
that is paul goldsmith at his best right
there no movement solid good swing
barrel homer here's yada year molina
and a nasty slider for the strikeout
that's his fourth of the game but lots
of power by the cardinals six up six
down for jack flaherty to start his
night maybe getting a little closer to
the zone make guys go after it a little
bit more
swing and a miss and strikeout
number 500 for jack flaherty in his
career victor robles
settled in as the everyday center
fielder for the nets you know missing
with the fastball up
overthrowing that fastball right there
[Applause]
and roblaise is punched out thanks to
the first base umpire and it brings in
paul de young dylan not running and
there's a ball outside first walk handed
out by ross first two have reached here
in the fourth carpenter who
struck out back in the second
and carpenter rips it past the shift
into center
carlson will score
matt on his way to second thrown out but
dylan carlson scores to make it five
nothing so runners at the corners for
jack flaherty
flaherty gets the bunt down it is fair
and a run will score
with two strikes
gets the bunt down to score paul de
young so flaherty helps himself that is
a really nice job by jack flaherty right
there josh belt coming in
like that
into the left field corner
soto heading for third
he will be held by bob henley and josh
bell
makes a loud sound taking it the other
way
next up josh harrison popped up to
second
and that's off the glove of molina up
and in
soto with a late break manages to score
bell to third and the gnats are on the
board
that ball's well hit to right
it'll back up edmond
bell scores easily and the nats get that
job done it's a six to two game here's
to young and a golden opportunity here
for the cardinals
the young cranks one
deep left
at the track at the wall grand
slam
grand slam paul young
they intentionally walk carlson
and de young
makes him pay he's being aggressive
there's justin williams a single to left
and a run scored walked in the fourth
and williams smokes one
out to center
gone
wow
wow
an absolute
rocket out to center and i'm not sure if
that's the fan that dropped the first
home run attempt or his father
grandfather no it's him he got it yes he
got a souvenir john gomez to strike out
in the grounder two
third front door on that one gomes takes
it deep to left
off the wall
harrison scores jan gomes into second
and it's 11-4
and with goldschmidt coming up two
runners in scoring position
goldie
diving stop by harrison
and a run will score play
[Applause]
the 2-2
strike him out
and the cardinals take game one of the
series by the final of 12 to five